the jurogan experience you told me he
got you [ __ ] up on a show
yeah edibles and it's like i said i
melted like what's the the guy my man
the flying jew
that's on this show yeah lee and
it i remember the first time i did it i
was looking
him and lee had eight lea like maybe
four
these little stars of death little chewy
edibles he ate like
four of them and and i and i'm looking
and he's literally over there melting
his eyes open and then i looked over
like an hour later it was like it was
like a blob of a person over there
so i'm like okay i'm never gonna be like
that on this show oh [ __ ]
a year later i'm literally
in there and he's like oh you know you
know
so i eat eat the edible and i'm seeing
it
and i i thought i was talking pretty
regular
at first and then all of a sudden i
noticed that it's like
yo i don't i don't think i'm speaking
correctly like
and like and he was like no you you
[ __ ] up you got church you
[Laughter]
yeah i'm like yeah man and so when i
look back and i'm like yo i was so
[ __ ] up
and i didn't even eat the i ate another
edible but the star he gave me that star
and this is what this is what people
learn about me
um when i lose i lose
when i win i win but i'm
never embarrassed to say without whipped
out on some [ __ ]
so i had i was already
messing with these mushrooms i was on
mushrooms and then
he gives me this damn star and i'm like
i told myself i'mma eat it i'm gonna eat
this star let me just talk
but i kept thinking about what other
people was telling me don't eat the
death star
don't eat the stone i'm like oh no joey
ain't gonna [ __ ] punk me out
[Laughter]
so i'm staying at the lows
and i literally stash the star
at the lows in this in in the room i'm
like
well when somebody find this they're
gonna have a good time i'm not gonna
have that [ __ ] on me
and then i stashed the mushrooms inside
the hotel someone saw a maintenance man
probably found them
and had a good time like i was i was
wasted i
they're too much those stars he's giving
them to me they're 250 milligrams
that's too much i've seen joe eat four
of those four thousand milligrams like
it's nothing
we were on a plane once and he had these
uh chiba chews i forget how many
milligrams they were several hundred
milligrams too
he pops two chiba shoes i'm nervous just
sitting next to him
i'm like are you [ __ ] serious he's
like joe rogan come on it's time to
dance with the devil
so we're on the plane in the middle of
the plane ride he leans over he grabs me
he touched me joe rogan i almost had a
pack attack
i almost i almost couldn't do it i
almost couldn't do it he goes but i'm
fine
and then he pulls out two more stars of
death and throws him and i'm like no it
was
like so he almost had a panic attack and
then two hours later we were on the way
to new york
grabs me by the shoulder tells me and
then pops two more
yo he doesn't give a [ __ ] he goes to the
basement
he goes right down there he wants to see
what's in the corners
what's this what's in there i don't i
don't even
understand how he could do so many
edibles i don't even know strange
he he had a what did he try to give you
to do um
an opioid he's like i got the last two
biscuits
i got these coffee myself like i was
like
i'm not doing it with you come on
like i said how do you even have them
and he's just two it's like two and a
half got the last two biscuits
biscuits i was like yo crazy but i love
it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other
apps and can download episodes to save
on data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience